how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some pretty big spider-man
news not only just
news in general but also some leaks that
we have to go over
leaks basically confirming the
spider-verse news basically confirming
the spider-verse and a statement from
michael waldron the head writer of the
loki series again
basically confirming the spider-verse
this really
really is hollywood's worst kept secret
at this point and maybe that's why they
haven't released the trailer yet
and no sadly i have not heard any
updates about the spider-man no way home
trailer
but in this video i'll tell you all the
new stuff that i have learned and do
know
and if you love spider-man and marvel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so let's start off by talking about
spider-man no way home
reshoots now if you've been following my
channel or you've just been looking
online you probably have known that
spider-man reshoots have been happening
for
about a week or maybe a week and a half
now so this isn't really news
however what the news is is that they
are actually doing the reshoots in la
and over the past couple of days guess
who has been spotted
in la all three different spider-mans
and kristen
dunst all of them over the past couple
of days have been spotted in la
and that's no coincidence since they are
doing reshoots in la so of course that
leads us to believe that they are all in
la to do reshoots for spider-man no way
home
it's actually kind of funny tom holland
was spotted going to a suicide squad
premiere
and based off of everything i've heard
that movie is fantastic so
i don't blame him at all andrew garfield
has 100 been spotted
in la so has toby mcguire but there has
been sort of a controversial picture
that i want to clear up
kristen dunst was spotted with a woman
that people claimed was deborah anne
wool
karen page from daredevil and this was
in la so a lot of people thought okay so
she's going to be in the movie because
matt murdock is going to be peter
parker's lawyer in the beginning of the
film so this makes sense
however debra and wool actually
commented on the photo and said that's
not me
so although i fully expect charlie cox
matt murdock to be
in the film i don't expect karen page as
it turns out this is just one of kristen
dunst's friends
however when the reshoots were announced
charlie cox did have to cancel going to
a comic con
and considering all the reports that
he's in the movie that is probably why
he had the cancel to go do some reshoots
and i just want to add that jacob battle
on is also
in la as well so basically the whole
rumored cast
is in la right now and spider-man
reshoots are happening in
la maybe a couple of them together there
at the same time could be a coincidence
but this is like
all of them so i'm gonna say this is not
a coincidence and it's definitely for
reshoots which basically tells us
again that all of them are in the film
but if you need more evidence don't
worry i have more for you in this video
let's move on to what loki head writer
michael waldron had to say
about working with the people who were
riding spider-man no way home
when writing loki michael waldron
admitted that he had to keep in contact
with the people at spiderman no way home
and the people at
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and here's what he said about
working specifically with the people
over at spiderman no way home
your production teams are constantly
communicating with those producing teams
to make sure that you're not screwing
each other up
i had the benefit on spider-man no way
home chris mckenna and eric summers
wrote that
i was their writer's pa on season five
of community
so i can call mckenna and get bullied by
him whenever i want but also
say hey what the hell are you guys doing
let me make sure
i'm not ruining it so there's
communication to the extent
that the creative teams themselves the
filmmakers the writers whoever can
become friendly
it certainly benefits the projects so
michael basically admitted right there
that while he was writing loki he
couldn't do anything to mess up
what was happening in spider-man no way
home loki was an incredible series and
it's a good thing we're getting season
two
however loki pretty much had one job
introduce
the multiverse explain the multiverse
destroy that sacred timeline
and send everything into madness this in
turn would set up
a ton of future projects for the mcu
spider-man no way home
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and of course long-term
secret wars now obviously spider-man no
way home is the first movie to come out
after the loki series the first movie
that connects to it at least we're not
including chung chi or the eternals here
but the next multiverse project after
loki is spider-man no way home but again
loki kind of just had one point
introduced the multiverse it's
spider-man away home that actually has a
lot of very calculated things happening
in the film
bringing in toby maguire spider-man
andrew garfield spider-man kirsten
dunce's
mj and it seems like there are very
specific things that have to happen
for them to come into this film which is
why loki's head writer michael waldron
had to consistently check
in with the people over at spiderman no
way home and if that wasn't enough we
have even more evidence of the
spiderverse in spider-man no way home
that comes in the form of good ol
reliable toy leaks
specifically the descriptions of some of
these toy leaks coming out they are
pretty specific
we have a few here so i'll just read
them and then we'll talk about them
after
and not only do these tease the
spider-verse but also the sinister six
the first one reads swing into terror
with the spider-man no way home
six-inch action figures with lots of
articulation and potentially multiversal
consequences
each figure draws its inspiration from
the movie and potentially
other movies too big tease right there
we then have one from hasbro that says
the future of reality has never been
less certain than
in spider-man no way home what madness
will be unleashed as peter comes face to
face
with unlimited possibilities just like
the possibilities of fun
you'll have with these deluxe action
figures extra action means extra fun
blasting goodness knows what through
magic new adventures
another big tease there especially
because it says unlimited possibilities
but then we have one more that reads
blast your way into
another universe with the spider-man no
way home hero blasters
these fun blasters let you bring the
movie adventures home provided you can
find a way back
at this point i think a lot of people
have considered the fact that no way
home probably is referring to people
going back to their own home universes
but as far as the spider verse is
concerned there are some pretty big
giveaways here
the first one says potentially
multiversal consequences and it's kind
of funny that they say potentially
multiversal consequences instead of
multiversal consequences i think this is
their attempt to
kind of keep people in the dark but
again we all know but then again it says
each figure draws its inspiration from
the movie
and potentially other movies too again
why i say potentially we know it's going
to be from spider-man 1
spider-man 2 the amazing spider-man 2
and maybe even another curveball thrown
at us
but still huge indication right there
the other one states that
what madness will be unleashed as peter
comes face to face with
unlimited possibilities of course when i
hear spider-man no way home when i hear
madness i think of multiverse of madness
and when you think of the multiverse you
think of
unlimited possibilities and of course
there's the one for the blaster that
says blast your way into
another universe and then it even says
provided you can find a way
back as in a way back home i mean it's
just kind of funny at this point how
much evidence that we do
have whether that's legit things that
have come out or leaks like this that
have come out i mean we've had
everything from
alfred molina talking about how he's
going to be in spider-man and where he's
going to pick up from as
in he's going to be taken from his
universe right before he dies
then you have jamie foxx posted on his
instagram about spider-man coming back
as elektro
then you have things like today where we
have all of these leaks talking about
the multiverse and the spider-verse and
then of course we get things like we've
gotten this week where the whole entire
cast is seemingly in la when they're
doing reshoots right now
in la so at this point it's actually
really hard to believe that they haven't
released the trailer yet
although i can say this i have heard
that promotion for
all of the other spider-man and the
other universes is not going to start
until about halfway
into the promotion so based off of what
i've been told we aren't going to see
toby and andrew in the very first teaser
but that's all i have today for
spider-man no way home let me know what
you think about all of these leaks and
news
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you